welcome to this talk about embedded
Linux
[Music]
um
yeah I was thinking about that so I've
been doing stuff with Linux embedded
Linux for too many years
um and interesting enough I when I came
to Linux I actually came to Linux as an
embedded operating system it was only
later on I discovered you could run it
on other computers too
so for me Linux has always been an
embedded operating system
and in fact if you look at the
deployment of Linux systems the vast
majority of systems are running on
embedded devices there are a few running
in on servers in server farms and such
like a very few on desktops but the
majority use case for Linux actually is
embedded
so I want to talk a little bit about
um what is embedded what is embedded
Linux and some of the attributes of
embedded systems
um
so first of all let me let's open it up
to the audience so what is embedded how
do you define embedded Computing anybody
have any uh any criteria how would you
recognize an embedded system
on chip
on one chip or two chips
one chip okay
on chip yeah
custom boards yeah embedded systems
typically do run on custom boards
at the back
any product with a computer inside
right when the computer is hidden inside
yes exactly yep yep like that
um anyone else
okay
well here's my list
I think yes
um so this is illustrates the problem
really that that
there isn't really a definition of
embedded Linux it's kind of whatever you
want it to be
um so I've kind of boiled it down to
this statement here
so in embedded well actually it doesn't
embedded Computing in general is just
code running on a computer inside a
device that you don't think of as being
a computer
so
um
yeah if if we look at my laptop if you
ask the the person in the street is this
a computer they're going to say yes
that's a computer
um if you point out your um
your your washing machine and you say is
that a computer they'll say no it's a
washing machine but it has a computer
inside it
so that's an embeddy computer
the tricky one is
what do people say if you say is this a
computer
most people probably would say it isn't
but blatantly it is a computer it's a
very powerful computer in fact
um so smartphones are kind of the
boundary between embedded and not
embedded
foreign
so some characteristics you'll look for
and really the more ticks you can have
in these bullet points here the more
embedded it is
so single use a typical embedded system
is a single use system
um it's not end user programmable so
typically I can't load new programs into
that system it's locked down it does
well it does the washing for example
um embedded systems are often designed
for price
uh particularly
um
kind of consumer electronics where price
is very sensitive
so for this reason we tend to use low
powered cheap computers
um Power constraints especially anything
that runs on a battery has power
constraints
and then also related to that but
different Power dissipation
in particular we really don't want to
use cooling fans we don't want what well
watch me it's not a good example in that
case but we don't want doorbells we
don't want a thermostat is a good
example we don't want a thermostat which
dissipates so much power that it warms
the room up
so different things so typically if you
have three or more ticks on that box you
probably have an embedded computer
so what kind of computer
um so here I've divided it into three
categories
uh we have microcontrollers which really
comes to your your on-chip your single
chip uh idea so with a microcontroller
you have a single chip which contains
the CPU and the memory and the storage
all on one chip
and these things tend to be very cheap
they can be from a few cents up to a few
dollars
and they are used indeed for washing
machines microwave ovens that kind of
stuff
then flipping to the opposite extreme we
have microprocessors mpus so
microprocessor is a chip which contains
only the CPUs and the logic surrounding
that
and then you have external
memory storage everything else is on
separate chips on a motherboard of some
kind
um so these are high power
high performance in other words
um but they also consume a lot of power
and they're quite expensive
and they are typified by PCS the PC
architecture
and then we have the third category
system on chip SOC which is maybe a
little bit of a combination of the two
so a system on chip uh contains a
microprocessor
um
and also some on-chip peripherals so
typically that would well these days at
least it would include a GPU a video
Processing Unit
um uh USB controllers I squared C
controllers
um everything that you need particularly
for a smartphone
but it does not include the ram the RAM
and the storage are separate that's the
key Point really
and the system on chip Market
um in this way is pretty much dominated
by arm at the moment
so if you are designing a product
um based around these system on chips
you have several choices this actually
also applies to uh x86 and the kind of
mpu Market
so you can start off with an SBC a
single board computer
so this is something which is a board
it has everything you need except you
just need to plug in power and some
peripherals keyboards USB whatever
but it's then fully ready to go so
Raspberry Pi is an obvious example of
that
also your PC
um then we have the system on module Som
so a system or module is an SOC
usually although you can also do system
or modules within with Intel based
systems
um but the key idea here is that you
create a little compute board
with some kind of connector uh either an
edge connector or some kind of
connectors underneath you you can plug
into a baseboard and then you put your
custom logic onto the baseboard
and the win here is that the expensive
part of Designing one of these things is
designing the CPU board itself because
that has high frequency Electronics on
it which is tricky uh you have all kinds
of design rules you need complex pcbs
with 10 12 14 layers that's quite
expensive especially in small volumes
so you do all that complicated stuff or
rather the the system or module vendor
does all that complicated stuff for you
and then you plug it into your baseboard
which is just a single simple two or
four layer PCB and there you put your
low frequency Electronics on top of that
yes question
I think I have one in the next couple of
slides yes I'll come to that in a moment
or two
um so the the Som is great for uh small
volumes
um of maybe a few thousand units a year
or something
um
and then we come on to fully custom
Hardware where you start from scratch
and you design the board including the
CPU and the high speed peripherals uh
yourself requires a certain design
skills to be able to do that but I mean
it's not it's not that hard
so
Som
um so this is a typical system a module
this is actually from a company called
Phi Tech but you can also go to toradex
vericite uh contron
um there are hundreds and hundreds of
companies doing these these system
modules
um they're mostly little they're not
they're mostly not huge companies
um size it's obviously smaller than it
shows on the slide uh kind of credit
card size typically
uh so this particular one is a an XP
imx8
so it's a quad core
um
fairly lightweight
um arm processor these days
um various configurations from between
one and eight gigabytes of RAM up to 64
gigabytes of flash it has a GPU built in
it has video processing has a display
controller he even has a little MCU
built in as little cortex M4 mpu built
in so you can do some real-time stuff on
that if you wish
um it's got ethernet controllers Wi-Fi
controllers Bluetooth controllers
various display display options and
peripherals for USB pcie and various
other things
so that's a very typical Psalm daycast I
don't know 100 200 something of that
sort
okay so that's the hardware view of
things
um yeah what about Linux
well okay let's first of all uh deal
with mcu's microcontrollers
basically biker controllers are not
powerful enough to run Linux
uh so most microcontrollers have uh at
most a few kilobytes
um or maybe hundreds of kilobytes of RAM
and maybe up to a megabyte of flash
memory
nowhere near enough to run Linux
so they run a real-time operating system
such as Zephyr is the the current flavor
of the day uh free artex nutex and a
bunch of others
so when we're talking about embedded
Linux we're really talking about
um the mpus and also the system on chips
and these are the kind of things that
are going to be running Linux in you
know in and around your home so this is
a vehicle system this is an ivi system I
think from
I think this is a BMW system if I
remember rightly
um it's going to be running Linux all
modern vehicles are running Linux in the
head unit
um smart smart TV sorry TV setup boxes
Smart TVs smart thermostats not smart
thermostats smart doorbells routers
security cameras they're all running
Linux
why
why do I need to run a 32 or 64-bit Unix
operating system on my TV I forgot sake
as a TV it just shows pictures
um
and the answer is that the TV of today
is not the TV I was using many years ago
my youth they have changed a lot
so it comes down really to first of all
Moore's Law 's law applies equally well
to embedded systems as it does to
desktops
so
the chips are getting exponentially more
complex
but for a given price point
um and so you need something complex
like Linux to control this device and to
give you the connectivity you need so
you need a a good networking stack
unique connectivity over Wireless
interfaces of various sorts uh you need
why you need support for USB and why and
Bluetooth
um
all of these things they come more
easily if you take a Linux system which
has all this built in
so we need a complex operating system
which operates operating system do we
choose
so the advantage of Linux uh first of
all it's free
so I'm using free in the term in the
sense here of freedom
uh you have the freedom to take the
source code to examine the source code
to modify the source code and to
customize it in any way you wish
it's open source in other words
next is functional
meaning that
Linux these days has support for pretty
much every piece of Hardware you can
imagine it is constantly been constantly
being updated
um it just works in most cases
and then finally uh free whoops wrong
button uh free in the sense of
you don't pay anything
so it's open source therefore you're
free to download the software and build
it into any product you want no charge
to pay
so these are all pretty compelling
things and this is why essentially Linux
is the dominant operating system in this
market
so let's move on from this then say okay
um my boss has just given me a board and
he says to me build Linux and make it
run on this board for me
so what would you need
well first of all it has to have a 32 or
64-bit processor it needs memory
management so Linux is a virtual memory
system you need a system with an mmu
so that rules out some of the cortex M
uh systems from arm for example
so typically they're the arm a class the
application processors also x86 uh risk
5 is becoming more and more important
plus about a dozen others which are less
used these days
how much memory actually not that much
if you simply want to boot a Linux
kernel and maybe get a get a command
prompt you can do that in as little as
16 megabytes
uh just about
um how much storage again if you just
want a Linux kernel and just a simple
busy box based system you could actually
do that in about four megabytes I
actually haven't tried this recently but
certainly that worked about five years
ago
um
and you can even go smaller
so people have tried to shrink Linux
down really in order as part of the iot
um
Revolution or whatever you want to call
it
um people have tried to put Linux onto
microcontrollers
and it is just about possible but it's
um
uh it well it requires non-tribal effort
to start with and you end up with
something that's not into easily
maintainable
so really and truly these are the very
minimum
numbers you could reasonably expect to
get to
having said otherwise most of the
devices you're going to be running I
have far more memory and storage than
those numbers so that's not usually the
big issue
so looking at now the general ecosystem
for open source in general and Linux in
particular
how does this all work
so first of all we have what I call the
open source community
so these are the various open source
projects that you need
in order to build your basic system
so obviously that's going to be Linux
but also the compiler support and the
libraries you'll need to go with it the
bootloader and a bunch of other things
so even from minimal system you are
going to need to draw from I don't know
100 or so different open source projects
each one of these is is governed in its
own way
but each of them is funded in its own
way as well so these people aren't
working for nothing these people are
being paid by somebody
um very few people do stuff for nothing
so this is the community it somehow
Works nobody knows entirely how it works
but it does work
then we have the soc vendors so these
are nxp Qualcomm TI and all those people
so they take this open source code in
particular the Linux kernel and they put
a lot of effort these days into making
sure that Linux works well on their
chips because they know that's what
people are going to be running
then the SBC and Som vendors and also
the custom if you're doing your own
custom Hardware you'll take the output
of the soc vendors and use that or they
use that in their own implementations
and then finally there are also a whole
bunch of people who will sell you uh
supported consultancy along those lines
and you know same in emailed and I'll
let you know what my rates are
foreign
pain points this is not a seamlessly
um seamless operation things go wrong
um we still have despite what I said
about Hardware support we still have
problems that
um quite often you get Hardware
uh from various places and you discover
that the Linux support isn't that great
or is kind of missing so you may have to
have some issues as resolve some issues
there
so quite often you're faced with a
peripheral from maybe a Chinese vendor
with documentation maybe in Chinese and
you'll have to kind of work your way
through that somehow
so it's not obvious the main thing I
want to say here really and I'm not sure
this applies to anybody in this room is
the main issue is that the
the hardware designers generally don't
talk to the software guys when they're
designing the board they just take the
cheapest bits they can find and plug
them onto the board
and then they give it to us
and we say why the hell did you choose
that peripheral there we know whoever it
is their drivers suck why didn't use
these other guys who may be a couple of
cents more expensive but they do do
decent support
so really the the point of this bullet
point really is that it'd be really
great if anybody's listening out there
if the hardware Engineers would talk to
the software Engineers before they
finish the hardware design
okay next Point
um the update Cycles
open source software is built on the
philosophy of release early release
often
which is a problem if you are building
um devices which have lifespans of uh of
years or even decades in some cases
such an unresolved issue I don't have
any great ideas of how to fix this
except you need to do buffering and you
need to
be prepared to put some effort into
supporting your devices
once they are no longer supported by the
Upstream projects or the sfc vendors
and then the final point is really a dig
at the particularly the soc vendors
um which is that they often don't do a
very good job of providing their
software
um
and I've been saying this for 20 years
and it hasn't made the slightest bit of
difference
okay so next point then
do you use a distro
or do you build from source
so by using a distro I mean using things
like Debian or Ubuntu or whatever
so why not these things exist they work
um there's no compilation involved you
just install the
um the ISO file or whatever into your
memory and anything that's missing you
just get using apt or dnf or something
this sounds like a great idea
but for reasons we're going to come to
in a couple of slides time it actually
doesn't work that well
the key thing here really is that native
disc sorry um distros generally are
built around the idea of native
compiling so if you want to rebuild a
package from a distro you'll have to do
that on the board itself
or at least on something that's
compatible with the board
and that doesn't fit well with typical
embedded development
so normally with embedded development we
actually want to keep the development
system separate from the actual Target
board
and for that we typically use cross
compilation
so that means we have a development
system on our PC we then cross compile
and then deploy to the Target board
that's the more natural way of doing
things
so distro plus is Yes Master packages uh
switch on and go
but the minuses
actually the the one of the biggest
minuses which I kind of skipped over is
that
distros don't have broad support for
every single Som SBC and SOC
so
unless you are using some kind of
commodity system such as Raspberry Pi
you're probably going to find that there
isn't a board support package available
for
whatever distro you choose for example
Debian
so that's a big break to start with
uh Native compilation like I say is not
generally what we want to do
size is also an issue
um you can shrink a distro Down
uh by leaving out stuff so a typical
distro when you install it from the net
is going to be four or five gigabytes or
something
you can shrink it down to maybe 500
megabytes and in the case of Ubuntu they
actually do a pre-packaged version of
that called Ubuntu core
uh and Debian have also a similar thing
which I've forgotten the name of
um but these are still several hundred
megabytes
sometimes that's too much sometimes we
maybe only have 256 megabytes to play
with so we can't afford to
use all that up just on a distro
and then there's a problem with how do
you update these things in the field
um for reasons we'll come to in a couple
of slides but towards the end of the
presentation actually
um doing package update using
um apt or dnf isn't really very robust
so as you can tell I'm not a big fan of
using distros there are cases when it
does work
um
so embedded PCS so things based on x86
little some boards or little sbcs based
on x86
um these often are running uh some kind
of distro Ubuntu for example
uh and also with Raspberry Pi like I say
Raspberry Pi is used a lot it embedded
using this thing called the Raspberry Pi
compute module
so the the CM the compute module is
basically an industrial version of the
Raspberry Pi and people using that
they're probably going to be using
raspberry and because that's the obvious
thing to use
and the key thing is that in all these
cases these are mostly low value systems
where human and Interventional human
intervention is possible if it goes
wrong
so there'll be somebody there to hit the
reset button when it doesn't boot
okay next topic let's talk a little bit
about bsps
um so ball support package this is the
stuff you need to make your board work
so the bsp you need a bootloader so you
need something that will actually get
the thing running to start with
you need Linux
you need a Linux kernel that is built
for your particular hardware and and
particular board perhaps
so typically that's going to be going to
be the vendor kernel from your silicon
vendor be it Qualcomm or nxp or whoever
um you'll need some kernel drivers so if
your board has some specific peripherals
you may need kernel device drivers to
make them work
you'll need a device tree talk about
device Tree in a minute
but you'll need a device tree to make it
work
then there may be some vendor-specific
libraries particularly for graphics you
typically will need opengl libraries
opengl libraries are specific to a
particular Hardware
and you may also need some G streamer
plugins using codecs built into the
hardware
then you need some boot scripts and
finally you may need some firmware so
a lot of these socs actually contain a
number of microprocessors
typically doing things like Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth and such like
and you need to load the firmware into
those before they're going to work
so where's that firmware going to come
from probably not you're not going to
write it it comes as a binary from the
sfc vendor
so all of this stuff together is what I
call the board support package
so in terms of architectures then for
arm and as other architectures you need
all these components
um plus if you're using something like
yoctaw or build root you'll need the
recipes to make all this work
so there's quite a lot of effort if
you're working on x86 things are
slightly different in the x36 world
essentially the board support package is
the BIOS
the BIOS is provided for you by whoever
made the board so typically you take
your embedded PC plug it in it will
at least boot up into the BIOS
as well as the BIOS there may be some
additional stuff you may have some
custom kernel drivers and such like but
because the PC environment is so
standardized
most things will work pretty much out of
the box
okay next topic
so I want to go back a little bit and
talk about the fundamentals of embedded
Linux and I want to talk about the the
four essential elements of embedded
Linux
actually this applies to any Linux
system
even for PCs for any system you need
these four things before you can get any
work done
so I'm going to talk briefly about tool
chains bootloaders kernels root file
systems
so you need a tool chain you need
something that's going to compile code
for you for your Target system
could be uh GCC it could be clang it
doesn't really matter
next you need a bootloader
so the bootloader is the thing which
from power on takes you to the point
where you can run Linux
um and as we've just said in the case of
x86 the bootloader essentially is the
BIOS
or at least the bias is part of the
bootloader
uh you need a kernel you need something
to you need to
you need to get a version of Linux which
is customized for your particular
hardware and board
and then finally you need a root file
system the root file system has the user
space components which are the init
system and the libraries and shells and
shell scripts and just basic demons
so two chains
um I'm not going into too much depth on
this but essentially tool chain is
um it's not just the the compiler it's
also the Linker Union C library and you
probably need a debugger unless you are
going to go without debugging stuff
um in most cases the compiler the
Lincoln debugger is going to come either
from GCC or from clang or you can
actually mix and match if you want to
when it comes to the C library you have
two choices you can either use glybc
um which is big and fully functional but
maybe a bit too big in some cases
or you can use Muscle Lipsy muscle is a
small smaller C library
handy for smaller format systems
tool chains native cross compile I think
we've covered this already in fact
you need a bootloader
so a bootloader is
actually we loaded there's a number of
things which I don't think I'm I'm
differentiating here so the bootloader
does
two fundamental things it has to do the
initial boot of the board so when the
bootloader starts to run the board is
not fully set up so it will include some
initialization code
to set up the CPU and peripherals maybe
set up the sdram controller all kinds of
weird stuff
so there's a whole bunch of early
initialization stuff that is part of the
bootloader
but then its main job once it's kind of
got the system up and running is to load
a Linux kernel into memory and set that
running
so bootloaders
the most common one is called dasubut
so uboot has been around for a long time
and it has support for thousands and
thousands of different boards
so you beat is probably a good place to
start
uh there's one called bear box uh which
essentially is derived from u-boot but
takes a slightly different approach to
things
it's a little bit specialized but people
do use it
uh there's one called little kernel or
LK for short
little colonel is relevant if you're
using Qualcomm devices so Qualcomm
um use little kernel exclusively as
their bootloader and I think a couple of
other manufacturers do I think mediatek
do for example maybe Rock Chip I don't
quite remember
and then for x86 uh use grub so I send
the bootloader as bio is the BIOS which
is correct so the bias does the early
initialization stuff you still need
something that's actually going to load
the Linux kernel and that would be grub
and there's some alternatives to group
grab but that will do for the moment
and then you need a kernel
um so no next non-x86 boards seldom use
Mainline Linux
in other words Mainland Linux generally
doesn't have support for the soc you
have to be running
so you need instead a vendor kernel
which means you have a dependency on
your SOC vendor
um
and that will then have code to
initialize the chip and set things up
correctly
may have some extra features so Qualcomm
for example has this thing called Energy
awareness energy aware scheduling which
is a whole bunch of code
and there may be some other peripherals
needed
this like I say is is a pain one of the
pain code pain points is that the
vendors don't update as often as
Mainline Linux does so typically they
only give you one update per year not
the four or five that you get from Linus
toll roads
uh also vendors are not very good at
pushing their changes Upstream so good
old Qualcomm for example I haven't
checked this figure actually in about
five years but about five years ago they
had 25 000 patches
on top of Mainline
25 000 patches that's over a million
lines of code that's a lot of code
and then still part of the device the
still part of the board support package
you're going to need a device tree
so hands up who knows what a device tree
is here just a lot of interest
oh okay
looks like maybe a third
which is good
so device trees why do we need a device
tree
so the thing is Linux when it boots up
it needs to know what Hardware is
running on top of
in order to know what device drivers to
load and how to configure those device
drivers
so how does it work this out
so in the case of x86
we have the BIOS and the BIOS has things
called acpi tables
so acpi has some basic information about
the peripherals on the motherboard
so Linux reads the CPI tables it can
initialize those peripherals
and then for everything else we have PCI
so all the other peripherals on a PC are
going to be attached to the PCI bus
so we just go through enumeration Cycles
on the PCI bus and we read about the
configuration for every single function
on the PCI bus
and from that we can identify the
hardware and also the resources it's
using and we can initialize the device
drivers
however
embedded devices don't have bios
embedded devices don't have PCI
or at least not as the course of a core
part of the system there may be PCI
added on afterwards but it's not part of
the core
so in that case we have a thing called a
device tree
which is a data structure tree obviously
which describes the hardware components
and everything apart from Intel uses
device trees
so arm risk 5 power PC Maps everything
else PCS x86 is the exception here
and then finally out of my four things
we have the root file system
root file system contains the user space
part of your system
um and at the very least must contain an
init Daemon because once Linux has
started booted stopped booting it will
want to run the init program and then it
hands over to user space
so at the very least you need an init
Daemon and then all the libraries that
depends on and then the executables for
the demons that that's going to start up
uh to do networking Authentication
logging everything else that you have to
do
so all of this stuff has to be put
together somehow
you can do it by hand if ever any of
you've ever done Linux from scratch or
embedded Linux from scratch you can do
this by typing commands and to be honest
I quite enjoy doing that it's quite fun
once
um but the third or fourth time it gets
a little bit tedious
so that's how that's literally how we
did do it in the early days
um but since about 2010 we've had some
pretty good build systems and nowadays
we can just throw things at the build
system and it will do everything for us
so build systems we have build Roots
open wrt open embedded yocto
of that burned yokto is by far the most
commonly used
but they all have their their their
niches
so build root
build root actually is the oldest of
those build systems it's the oldest
build system that's still being used and
maintained
um
and it supports pretty much everything
you want it supports um it has about two
and a half thousand packages
board configurations for a couple
hundred boards and so on so build is
actually quite nice it's menu driven
um you just go to scroll through the
menu select the things you want and then
you just type make and it goes away and
builds it all
the snack with build route however is it
doesn't really scale very well
um it
um the way the way the data is stored
means you can't easily share that data
with someone else
and so if you have a team of more than a
few people which who are working closely
together then you rapidly find the point
that where build root doesn't scale so
Builder is great for small systems uh
it's really great for demo projects and
things but it's not really for
complex tasks
open embedded then uh open embed it
started a little bit after build route
and
it has a couple of useful Concepts in
addition to what buildroot has the main
one really is this concept of layers
so a layer contains a bunch of recipes
recipes are basically a recipe as the
instruction to build something and if
you've just been through my previous
presentation you'll know exactly what a
recipe is
but the key thing here then is layers
allow you to easily move chunks of
information
recipes
from one develop one environment to
another so you can share this between
different departments in an organization
and there's also third-party layers for
useful things like the QT libraries or
SE Linux or whatever and you can just
kind of incorporate those
so part of open embedded is something
called open embeddy core
um unless you you'll see in a moment why
I'm talking about this so OE core is the
core is the minimum you need to make
open embedded work
and it's used by various projects
um the key one is the Octo project which
I'm coming on to the next slide but also
um various other organizations use OE
core to use their own to create their
own build system
so that brings me on to yocto project
now the Octo project then is
a
uh a Linux Foundation sponsored project
and because of the
well the the the Kudos and the marketing
and the whatever that gets yokto has
become the main way that people uh use
in order to get open embedded in order
to build reliable systems
so most people talk about yokto project
um which is just an umbrella around
various components including open
embedded
so if you want a definition the Octo
project is OE core Plus bit big plus
Pocky which is
the Octo Project Specific
uh plus some reference bsps a bunch of
documentation and a graphical user
interface which nobody ever uses
okay so that was it about build systems
any any questions about that I'm kind of
going through this and bubbling on a
little bit
um this is kind of a bit of a random
selection of things anybody any
questions on the stuff I've done so far
before I go but go on to the next link
or you can wait till the end yes sir
oh people use all kinds of languages
um so yeah so the the basic operating
system is built in C and C plus plus
because that's how it's written
um but robust is also becoming
significant there I think
um but when it comes to the application
layout so I'm not really talking about
the application layer here I'm just
talking about the operating system layer
but when it comes to writing
applications
um python is pretty popular
um it's you know it's it's a nice
language to work with people use
JavaScript node.js and all that kind of
stuff
not quite sure where I what I think
about that
um but you can also write in go and and
I don't know if there's a language
there's support for it somewhere
so I would say that the the the
application Level these days is mostly
written probably in Python and and
various flavors of JavaScript
yeah but you can use C plus plus if you
want
depends what you're doing I mean
certainly when it comes to the graphical
layer so the graphics is mostly written
using cute QT you can use qml which is
the the description language which sits
on top of that
um but cute is is inherently a C plus
plus Library
so did anybody have so many questions I
think you're coming over here because if
I stand there I get blinded by that
light
look oh yes get back
I would like to know the answer to that
myself so the question is why are
silicon vendors so bad uh pushing code
Upstream
I could say all kinds of things uh which
could be inflammatory
um
but I I think the truth is that and this
is not just silicon vendors but Hardware
vendors in general they are kind of
focused on shipping Hardware
and to them software is not their
priority so software is just a drag
they don't make money at least they
don't make money from from selling Linux
so there isn't a huge incentive for them
to do a particularly good job there the
incentive the the incentive is simply to
do a job that's good enough to be able
to sell the product
and even more than that
is hit and miss
so I think that's the fundamental reason
it's kind of an economic thing
the best thing you can do
as as consumers of this is to refuse to
buy the Silicon unless they fix the bugs
unfortunately you have to be a really
big player for this to have any
significance but if everybody were to do
this if you would have wrote with your
feet and say no I'm not using your chip
because your support sucks that would
maybe persuade them to do better support
again I've been saying this for 20 years
and hasn't made a slightest bit of
difference so I don't expect this to
really happen but it would be nice
exactly yes I mean I mean in an Ideal
World all of this stuff will be upstream
and I would just be able to go to
Mainline Linux kernel.org download their
kernel and it should just work
and that does work pretty well for x86
but it doesn't really work for anything
else
um
you just have to live with it I'm afraid
okay oh sorry
yeah so Raspberry Pi is is popular and
embedded even though it's not a
particularly good embedded processor
um so in the in the grand scheme of
things you would not use a Raspberry Pi
because you know well for various
reasons however because it is commodity
Hardware it's commonly used it's well
supported
um there are whatever tens of millions
of them uh in in the in the system then
people do gravitate towards Raspberry Pi
uh for embedded systems
hopefully they're using the compute
module because I really don't like the
idea of a Raspberry Pi with an SD card
in there running an operating system of
an SD card is not a good idea SD cards
are not robust
um whereas the compute modules have emmc
memory which is which is robust
so if you think about it don't use a
Raspberry Pi per se user Raspberry Pi
compute module they are they are
industrial quality
okay so moving on then I've got a couple
more things to do not very much actually
real time open source
and that's it
so real time so
in many people's mind embedded in real
time a kind of co-mingled as being kind
of the same thing but really they're not
so I feel nevertheless compelled to talk
a little bit about real time here just
to clarify a few things
so first of all real time is
uh means that you have a computation
which must be completed by some deadline
so examples
anything to do with motion control
that is inherently a real-time task
because you need to decide the the um
the speed and direction of the robot or
the robot arm or whatever within the
next second or something before it hits
something so you have to continually
recompute uh where you are and where you
want to be and then set the the wheels
in the right direction
so that's a very obvious real-time thing
also we have things like displaying a
video stream
so video is a real-time thing you get a
new frame 30 or 60 or whatever frames
per second
so you have one frame period in order to
take that frame and display it on the
screen
so that's a real-time task
anything that doesn't have a deadline is
not real time
so for example compiling a program is
we would like it to happen as quickly as
possible but if it takes a minute or an
hour or a second
so long as it's due as long as the the
compiler is correct then the the output
is just as good
so there isn't a solid deadline as to
when that compilation has to complete
so we can talk about real-time metrics
um
and we really when it comes to real time
what we're really talking about is
determinism
so it turns out that computers are
highly non-deterministic
despite what it says in the books
and if we look at a typical graph so we
have some event happens at T naught we
have a deadline called TD
and these lines here are meant to
represent when the the output was was
ready
so you can see first of all there's a
range of times when the output was
created and we call this the Jitter
so this is the variance in creating and
Computing the output
and in this example on the slide this is
a not very well behaved real-time system
because we have some cases where we miss
the deadline
so that means that the the system failed
to some extent
so in order to make this system real
time what it really means is we need to
take this graph we need to move
everything over to the left and we also
need to reduce that Jitter so we need to
reduce the the length of time here
or that the variance of time here
so like I said there are two things to
consider first of all how long is it
between t t 0 and TD if this is a
millisecond then that's quite tricky
if this is like 10 seconds then anybody
can do that
so shorter deadlines are harder
the other thing which people often
forget is how much do you care
how much do you care about missing the
deadline does it really matter if we
sometimes miss the deadline
the more you care the harder it is
and ultimately if you care absolutely
that we must never miss this deadline
it's actually quite difficult to prove
that your system will never will never
exceed the deadline
you the only way you can really do that
for sure is mathematically and in order
to do a mathematical static analysis
analysis of a system you need something
that's far simpler than than Linux you
need basically a bare metal
um
MCU type system so that's why actually
most real-time Computing is not done on
powerful application processes for real
time we tend to use MCU as
microcontrollers microcontrollers you
can write them bare metal you can write
simple polling Loops which have
guaranteed response times that's how you
do real time
nevertheless there are some real-time
things that we can't avoid here on a
Linux type system so
we often talk about soft and hard wheel
type
so with soft real time we're a little
bit relaxed about about missing the
deadline
and a typical example of this is some
kind of video processing
so
nobody's going to notice if you miss a
sample now and again
uh it's not good it's not a good thing
but nobody's going to die and
probably the the end user is never going
to notice the odd frame missing
so we can be very relaxed about this as
long as we can hit the deadline 99 of
the time or 99.99 of the time or
whatever we're okay
the tricky one is really the hard real
time thing
so missing the deadline is never
acceptable
because missing it means that something
has gone wrong you may cause some damage
to to some equipment
um in extreme cases you may call in
cause injury or death so you can imagine
the braking system of a vehicle as we
said the other day
um it's no use if when you press the
brake you get a little little waiting
symbol uh waiting to apply the brakes
and then apply the brakes but it's too
late
there is this famous quote by Linus
so he says controlling a laser with
Linux is crazy but everybody in this
room is crazy in his own way
so I think that probably applies to us
as well
so if you want to use Learners to
control an industry in World industrial
welder welding laser I have no problem
of you using preempt RT I'll talk about
preempt RT in two slides time
so what can we do about real time and
Linux
so I'm going to talk about user space
and color space
so first of all in user space the key
thing of course is you use real-time
scheduling
so Linux has multiple uh scheduling
policies but the key ones are sched
normal and scad fifo
so sket normal is the default it's what
we call the completely Fair scheduler
and it guarantees to have to give each
thread a fair share of the CPU
but obviously it is not deterministic
then we have sket fifo so this is a
priority based scheduling algorithm we
have threads with priorities from 1 to
99 with 99 being the highest
and the algorithm is quite simple
the scheduler prefers to run scared fifo
so it will run all the sched 50 threads
until there are none left and it runs
them in priority order
only when there is no real-time threads
do we run the the normal threads so the
real-time threads always preempt the
normal threads
so your real-time staff skate 50 the
non-real-time staff schedulable
also when it comes to Linux
[Music]
um
as hinted by the the comment from uh
from lennis torbolds
the key thing here is preemption within
Linux
so uh Linux is a source of
non-determinism caused mostly by
scheduling latencies called by interrupt
handlers and locking
um
algorithms uh and a few other things as
well
you can change the behavior of Linux by
setting uh kernel preemption so first of
all you can set config preempt
that means the condo is now preemptable
which means that if we get an interrupt
whilst we're running kernel code we will
jump uh we will respond to that
interrupt and maybe do a reschedule and
then run a high priority thread
so that's fairly non-controversial but
it's not turned on by default on some
systems
so but it is enable the most embedded
kernels it's not embed enabled on
desktop systems
so that's good that gives you Jitter of
the order of milliseconds maybe tens of
milliseconds but it's not too bad
and then we have preempt RT RT Central
real time obviously
that does a whole bunch of things
which makes Linux far more deterministic
and you can get Jitter of the order of
hundreds of microseconds or even tens of
microseconds in some cases
so this is approaching quite a good
real-time system
why don't we enable these things by
default well because they slow the
system down actually real time is not
fast real time is deterministic
if you want a fast system you want it to
be non-deterministic
and that's the thing that people often
mistake
so the more deterministic your operating
system is actually the slower than the
fewer number of bytes you can process
per second
um almost out of time but I'll just do
I've got like three slides to go
quick work about uh software update
we need to be able to do atomic updates
and you cannot do atomic updates using
um
things like apt and dnf so package
managers are of no use here they if you
get a power down halfway through an apt
update you're going to corrupt the
system
that's fine if it's a desktop you can
hit the reboot button you can
if necessary type some things but if
your system is on the seabed or on a
mountain or somewhere else inaccessible
that's of no use
so we tend to do redundant images so you
have a b
images you boot from the a partitions
and then you apply the update to the B
partitions when the update's complete
you flip the flag so next time you
reboot your boot from the B partitions
and then you'll update the a partitions
and you just ping pong between the two
so that's a very common way of doing
things SW update rail Commander are
typical tools for doing this
uh oh okay okay a couple slides about
about licensing I'm going through this
quite quickly because I know people are
probably anxious to
make the train
let's quickly talk about licensing
um
so
we have two types of license essentially
we have permissive and and copy left
licenses the permissive licenses are
things like BSD and MIT and such like
they are fairly easy to work with they
basically say you can do whatever you
like with this code except you can't
change the copyright and you can't
change the warranty everything else is
fine
and then we have the copy left licenses
which are the GPR type licenses
now these are good licenses I like them
very much but they do have a bit of a
bad reputation
the main difference then is with GPL it
says that
you must distribute the source code to
your end users
so any changes you make to the source
you must give to your end users either
by just making it publicly available or
you can do a thing called a written
offer which means that if they contact
you you will promise to give them a copy
of the source code
um there's the lgpl which applies to
libraries which I'm going to skip over
and then we have version three of the
GPL which is the point one that gets
people really excited
so version three which came out in 99 or
something it's quite an old license now
the key part is this right to Tinker
so the key part of the gpl3 says that
you must be able to update
the end system with any GPL components
so that means that you must have a
mechanism to apply software updates for
end users to be able to apply software
updates to whatever device it is
so this leads to the problem then what
happens if I have a secure system and
I've implemented secure boot so secure
boot means I'm uh I'm assigning my
kernels with some encryption keys and
then the bootloader checks those keys if
they don't match it won't boot
that obviously is not compatible with
GPL V3
so the question is can you do secure
boot
uh with gpl3
and for a long time I thought it wasn't
but actually I came recently across this
talk by Bradley Kern and behan Webster
both of whom I trust has been has known
what they're talking about and this
actually is from 2017 so this is not a
new thing but here's to me so I'll just
say go and have a look at that but
essentially the the the short form of
this is that yes it is possible
to have secure Boot and gpl3 components
on the same system
if you do this special what they call
Dev board
where was it
uh yeah if you have this special Dev
board mode in other words we can boot up
with a non-secure boot
uh in order to run the GPL components
but you do not probably run the
proprietary components which are going
to do whatever it is your system does
so you can boot up you get a shell
prompt but that's it and that's that
that's the way the TiVo set top box
works you can actually boot a sibo set
box with your own kernel but it won't
actually stream any video
okay um apologize for running over I
didn't realize I had quite so much to
say so um just a quick conclusion then
well
the world is run by embedded Linux these
days thankfully
um there's a lot of Technology involved
in doing all this stuff it's evolved a
lot over the last 20 years
and it's been my life essentially
so the slides are available at this link
uh you can also contact me
um via Twitter and you can link with me
on LinkedIn
okay so
um
if anybody wants to run for the train
now is a good time to do that
but I'm also happy to hang around for
some time to answer any questions
so if you're not in a hurry
um feel free otherwise feel free to uh
to to make a dash